el Partido Conservador republicano nuevo
camino al elegir a la primera mujer
candidata a la Presidencia para las
elecciones de 253 la política de 54 años
fue ascendiendo en las filas del partido
los republicanos hasta llegar al primer
puesto haciendo historia
hoy tengo buenas noticias queridos
amigos la derecha republicana ha vuelto
la derecha con sus convicciones su
soluciones está unida y entra en la
lucha con un impulso implacable porque
Francia ya no puede dejarse esperar
Escuela Nacional de Administración
conocida por formar políticos y
presidentes franceses
fue una de las preferidas de los
conservadores con Jack shirak como
mentor y ocupó varios puestos
ministeriales con Nicolás Sarkozy en
2015 fue elegida como jefa de la región
Ildefons siendo reelecto en el año 2021
porque se ha dedicado a su trabajo
electo nunca perdió de vista sus
ambiciones nacionales 2017 se distancia
del partido de los republicanos y lanzó
sus propios movimientos llamado libre su
lema es liberal en la economía pero duro
en la ley el norte fue todo un éxito un
centenar de alcaldes diputados y otros
consejeros regionales se sumaron al
movimiento
si bien es cierto que por el momento va
de última en los sondeos como un 10 % en
la primera vuelta la moderada probó
empresarial podría ser un dolor de
cabeza para el presidente Emmanuel
Macron